Smith Allah peace be with you thank you
for tuning into the dicho there's some
crazy stuff going on out there we have
the LAX terrorism attack that happened
recently you have the new jersey
attacking the mall we're going to be
talking about this and much more with my
next guest actually got an open mind now
look look my next guess who i'm not
saying looks identical to him but will
resemble him in his dress and his beard
looks like jesus peace be upon him
possibly look look have an open mind we
got so much to talk about all this crazy
stuff and more here on the Dean show
will be right back
mrs. the
this is the thing you this is the days
of the engine you know this is the
things I Salam alaikum peace be with you
while it was an hour long piece with you
as well how are you email about if I'm
doing great how are you good good good i
opened the show and I said look my next
guest resembles Jesus look in the dress
sermon of the mount the beard all the
prophets had beards Jesus wasn't a white
boy ok he was some medic and have you
ever had that told to you that you
resemble someone like like Jesus with
the beard yeah I have a member one time
I was actually at the gym playing
basketball went into the locker room and
was just washing my hands of one of the
little children told his father a father
look that guy looks like Jesus and he
does he just smiled had nothing on the
same side smiling good words yeah most
people don't know that we love Jesus is
it true now that you cannot be one who
has submitted consciously to the crater
that happens on earth a Muslim unless
you believe love Jesus that's absolutely
true definitely just too right that's
very true that God so loved the world
that he said prophets and messengers to
guide mankind that's how God shows his
love doesn't he by sending people like
geez messengers like Jesus Moses Abraham
the last fight and finally mr. Pro
Muhammad to guide us that's that's
absolutely correct now you're any mom
you know the text did any of the
messengers ever I mean I'm sure you
studied some do some comparative
religion any of them ever call that
Jesus or any other messengers call
people to wishing themselves never never
no they only call to worship of the one
god no so why do you think now when
people see you for instance you know
they attribute okay look what tell this
guy like go back home and go back to
your country and and they don't think
like--look Jesus had a beard if he was
one of my guests was on the show the
other day he said look if the TSA
stopped Jesus he would get the tame but
why do you think people have you know
this is just ignorance obviously but you
know what would you say if someone told
you to go back home well the one if some
and told me to go back home number one I
wouldn't respond because as we have one
of the great companions of the Prophet
peace and blessings be upon him who only
taught them the best of morals and
ethics that he mentioned that better
than to respond better than responding
to one who's ignorant is remaining quiet
and not subscribing to his ignorance and
that's when an individual calls out and
says to go back home it's a clear sign
of the ignorance and that they haven't
understood what me RF kamat other
Muslims represents number one as human
beings as Muslims and if they did they
wouldn't say anything like that because
they would recognize the values and the
benefits that the original religion of
Islam would could bring to the society
and does been to the side society if
they see and are openly looking at what
the Muslims who practice Islam truly
bring to the community so that that
would be my response just no response
and if they would like to engage in a
dialogue then I would engage in a
dialogue peacefully and explain to them
how what they are saying is incorrect
Islam and nothing to do with what could
have possibly provoked that statement
and you know try to help them understand
and so that's what I would do and I
would number one not assume that that
this person is you know trying to cause
violence or trying to spread mischief
but I also myself will remind myself to
be a practicing Muslim because as
Muslims if we practice the faith there's
an only enlightened the people's
understanding of what Islam represents
and they would never have any chance to
make a statement like that they're many
examples of this i mean my brother i
give example i give an example of mr
sherlock is he he's he's he used to work
at a cafe like i said i was i was at a
gym when that whole thing happened
lifetime the very famous Jim throughout
North America or united states rather so
he used to work at a cafe with many
non-muslims and when the whole thing
about Islam preaches violence or things
were being said in the news his
co-workers would look at what the news
is saying and they would see the news
and what they are saying and there
remember my brother who I'm by the way a
twin my 20 year so he's insane identical
twins so they would say I know him he
worked at me he's a Muslim and he's the
nicest person I know Islam definitely
doesn't preach that because they're
saying Islam preachers violence but the
only thing I know about Islam from base
based upon what a deal shows me is
kindness and compassion and this is what
I know Islam represents so this is it
would just be a reminder to me first and
foremost as well to be a practicing
Muslim so that people can only have a
good impression understanding of what
Islam represents and if you were to go
back home where would you go back
bolingbrook illinois I'll come right
back Chicago Illinois because that's I
was born you were born in Chicago yes so
you wouldn't have to go too far I don't
have to go to [ __ ] my card say I'm back
home already yeah so that's really
ignorance I mean you're telling someone
to go back home who's an American
citizen was born here who looks like
Jesus okay so you know it's it's really
sad and and some sad events are
happening now we had the LAX shooting
you have some right-wing zealot who had
a huge manifesto who wasn't insane who
went shot up some people put innocent
lives in jeopardy and we know that Islam
condemns you know killing of innocent
men women and children but people always
want to link you know if this was a
Muslim people always want to link you
know any kind of horrific terrorist act
anything bad they label this person's a
terrorist but now we see you know these
sad events happening but the people
aren't being labeled terrorists what are
your thoughts on this well my thoughts
are that number one just as you
mentioned Islam definitely condemns the
taking of innocent lives as Allah God
mentioned in the holy quran that man
patel enough Samuel enough sin alpha
said in film if economic Patera message
any on the river takes the soul of one
person unjustly or even causes any type
of corruption and here it is as if he is
you know he has killed all of mankind so
even the killing of one in his insult
has been equated with killing all of
mankind showing that just as it would be
a great act a great act of injustice to
take the life of all of mankind the last
row of mankind to take a life of one
individual is just as unjust in the eyes
of Islam
people doing this is a very sad thing if
we look in the life of the Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
not only did he show respect for people
who are living even showed respect the
lives of Allah that God decided to take
back even one time there was a funeral
prayer and they were bringing it was a
funeral prayer of actually or non-muslim
and the Prophet peace upon him he saw
this funeral prayer taking place where
he stood up and his companion said why
are you standing up and he said because
God gave a life and God take a life and
I am standing to respect this older guy
took I've heard this narration also and
I believe this person was even a Jew
that's correct is it right Denari I was
a Jew yes that's very that's correct and
he was shown respect for this exact life
exactly so I was deep that's very deep
it shows the true teachings and a few
teachings of Islam but respecting one
another and even when you look in the
air when Islam was most purely being
implemented the Muslims were living
successfully in a pluralistic society
and in the time in the in medina in
medina 2mon awara the neighbors are the
Muslims were not necessarily Muslims
they were Jews and the Prophet peace
upon him often reminded the Muslims to
treat your neighbors well that just as
you have to treat your brother as well
you have to treat your neighbor as well
and even to such an extent that even if
you are cooking food and they can smell
the food that you are cooking that could
be a sign you know people like tea yeah
so one day one day when they smell good
food even if they're hungry it you know
it it builds your appetite they want to
it distracts them for a moment so just
because the food could have caused that
type of distraction to the neighbors of
the Muslims or non-muslims the Prophet
saws on the Prophet peace the panel
would say you must give them some of
your food because you distracted them be
kind to them their shows the the ethics
and the moral behavior that Islam
preaches so it's very sad to see that
events like this taking place in the
news that not only does Islam condemn
this and when a Muslim who is in
practicing Islam does something like
taking innocent lives to see that it is
being labeled as a Muslim practicing
Islam other islam teaches this that's
very
you said and its people are being
misinformed because that is not what
Islam represents and nor are we saying
that they should put their label on any
other religion but the fact is that the
person he committed and just at and you
shouldn't put blame on a religion but
put it on the person to perform that
action which is which is unjust so it's
very sad and you know we ask we has got
to allow us to understand the true
values of life and islam absolutely it's
like saying that you know the slaw
represents terrorism it's kind of making
a comparison like saying that the KKK
represents Christianity but exactly what
you see yeah so you know any any person
with some scruples no that's that's not
that's not right so obviously you know
when you meet a Muslim and then you
think like and you reflect and you and
you look at like when we started a
program you know we started with peace
be unto you Jesus greeted his followers
with peace exactly say what's up buddy I
said shall I more Lake peace be with you
and he had a beer just like you and he
was if you go right now and you go to go
to google and put Jesus Sermon on the
Mount he had what you're wearing now
someone say why are you trying to are
you trying to really emulate Jesus and
the prophets well the idea is is that if
we have to take an example of
individuals when we want to follow what
better example take than that of the
prophets and as Muslims we respect and
love all prophets including Jesus kiss
upon him when you read the descriptions
of Jesus peace be upon him we see that a
like description is given of that of
this of this garment and likewise the
garment of the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him and we believe that we receive
guidance we don't believe it we know
from the from the word of a garden to
put under we were probably Muhammad
peace in fondant was the mode the way we
will receive we receive guidance so we
love all of his actions and the fact
that he wore a garment like this is very
beloved to us so we like to emulate him
so modesty modesty is artist is key
modesty okay so this does that
flexibility in Islam so if you if that's
your right you want to dress like that
modest hey most people are dressing in
modest right you know what I mean so now
to put someone down because they want to
just modest and they want to emulate
look the prophets that's really an
ignorant thing to do we got some more
your we
talk a little bit more about you so much
to talk about with a community leader
memorize the verbatim word of God Imam
out of here and the Dean shall we write
back with more don't go anywhere is that
if Jesus himself was to try to get into
JFK airport or o'hare airport oh you got
to find out for yourself you got to read
the you got to read the crime it is
literally the Word of God you know with
bushy black hair probably wearing a joke
Bob you know a little oh and I'll tell
you it answers all your questions it
does and that's why slam is so prevalent
in the world today see if you drop me
from a helicopter anywhere in the world
and a parachute unless you want to
believe that human beings by nature are
stupid it's starting on door a door and
shaking people's hands on it would be
hard for you to believe that two billion
of them can choose a religion that is a
work of violence I would eventually find
a Muslim who will put their arms around
me drag me into their house and feed me
till I according to eat it mean to milk
two billion people this isn't 200 people
yeah you know how did these people from
China to Mauritania to you know Spain
put purpose to our life to America
Canada Australia Brazil all over the
world Middle East Africa you know how
did all these people the one thing that
I've noticed a lot when you're more
selfless and you realize you're serving
other people arrive at the same
conclusion but this religion is a good
religion for them and you're serving a
higher power very quickly your problems
become very minuscule it's not because
they're violent and hateful and because
the you know they're psychologically
disturbed to the contrary if there was
one message that I had to send any money
it would be because they're seeking
peace and they found peace in slow he
read the Quran and find out for yourself
back here on the DS show with imam Arif
from the bolingbrook community center
not me to the must mosque in bolingbrook
and you're the the community leader
there right that's correct you're the
Imam that's correct any mom for the not
yet Muslims out there what does he mommy
this is a spiritual leader right you can
say the Imam is a spiritual leader
community leader to help guide other
community in regards to other aspects of
their religion and their spirituality
and often times anything is going on in
their life that they need upliftment so
they come to the imam and however the
amount can serve them as the obama has
dedicated his life to the service of
people he tries to help ease their
situation provide whatever guidance you
can with the help of God now just for
the the help of teaching people you know
I'm gonna ask this questions for the
people i don't know is there any are you
like clergy like people have to pray to
you to get the god right or is there any
of this in islam of course not
everyone's really everyone's
relationship with God is an independent
relationship it doesn't have to come
through me or anyone any holy person
known in Jesus Mohammed nobody no no
just direct dialogue it's direct they
have a director secretary message that's
deep because people don't like being put
on hold we're gonna go through somebody
right right exactly because most people
now they say look you know you have to
go through Jesus to get to God you have
to go through a saint you have to go to
a Deborah this guy was to you know God's
to holy and this person was a righteous
person so now you got to go through them
to get to God I mean in Islam it cuts
all of this out right we have an
independent relationship but no doubt we
see the best example in how we should
conduct our relationship with God in the
prophets in the pot in the messenger in
the example that the prophets have given
and the Prophet Muhammad peace upon that
he's given so we look as him to him as a
role model and we look up to him and how
we should conduct our relationship with
God but our relationship with that is
definitely independent relationship and
that's what most people who have
accepted the fastest-growing way of life
in the world today Islam submission to
not the creation but the Creator the one
who created everything our maker the
maker of mankind the one who Jesus
worship Moses Abraham and last final
mission they all call people not to
worship themselves but to worship the
creator and they love this
this direct connection with God that you
don't go through any middleman and I
worshiping anyone but the Creator people
love this is something you know that's
unique it just fits with the human
inclination you know what's inside my
that's exactly that's exactly correct
because as human beings we just as we
need to nourish our bodies only to
nourish our we need to give our
spirituality nourishment as well and we
get that when we when we build our
relationship with God that contentment
that we get is something that is very
precious and that's why when individual
begins to become a devout Muslim and
they understand appreciate it and began
to feel level of contentment they only
begin to become more dedicated to the
level of devotion at the show to their
religion you said a devout Muslim
something now some red flags just went
up some people think oh that's where the
problem comes in now he's a devout most
he's a you know he's a fun fanatic they
attribute that with devout being fanatic
you know how far is this from the truth
I mean that's the that's very far I mean
there's what we when we look an example
examine the life of the Prophet peace
upon him was a very moderate lifestyle
there was no fanaticism to any in to any
extent the perfect peace upon him was as
Allah says no Quran Oh Martin was a
poorly takuna shuhada alertness that
this is the middle nation of moderate
nation there's no fanaticism so that is
that is very far from the from the from
the tree doesn't islam teaches this is i
mean this is a fact not fiction not only
do we believe in love jesus already
people have learned that that he was one
of the mightiest messages of god he
never called people to worship himself
nor do any of the prophets but he called
people just like the last final mr. prob
Muhammad Moses Abraham and all the other
messengers they call people to worship
the One God and they called us to be
extremely kind extremely nice extremely
merciful that's that's the antithesis to
being like some roughneck dog is it I
mean it mentioned the Prophet peace upon
says in the in the Holy of Quran that do
not worship the Sun or the moon or other
worship God directly yes what's
generally let Olivia fall upon worship
the god along with created them and
everyone else so worship him directly
what the Prophet was gone yeah not the
moon on the Sun not the Stars nothing
not a human being just worship the
Creator you've memorized the right this
is one of the miracles that we have is
testable today something tangible you've
memorized very very young in your
community leader you know the mom and
you've also memorized the verbatim word
of God that if anyone takes a look at it
and a little analytically scientifically
they'll see that this can't come from a
human being and you memorizes your one
who's a half it who's who's carrying it
in your mind in the heart that right
that's correct a one in over 20 million
in the world amazed one in over 20
million in the world it's definitely a
great blessing I've gotten it shows that
this word is the true Word of God that
something like this could be memorized
and it could be regurgitated and
retained it hasn't been any other book
and God promises that it can take place
with this book and an easy manner and
the fact that I'm only one out of over
20 million in the world that I've done
so just attests to that fact that's
amazing and now I want you to also tell
us you know there's a lot of
misinformation about Islam you know and
usually they don't bring on the experts
people who really live this way of life
practice it who are devout devoutly
merciful devoutly living this way of
life that brings peace happiness
contentment a true purpose of life so
now when these stations they bring out
people who don't represent Islam the
right way just you know not only do they
give light to many of these people who
the one percent not even that who do
some extreme elements you know they go
ahead and have people who have some
twisted views on Islam Jesus peace be
upon him home to ask you there was a
someone else so I'll show clip real
quick well Jays LOM doesn't believe that
Jesus was crucified first of all Islam
believes in the virgin birth I mean
Jesus was most definitely crucified and
my book does question the historicity of
the virgin birth you had this individual
we showed this clip talking about that
we know as Muslims we believe that God
Almighty sent Jesus to warn the people
of the Hellfire to give the glad tidings
of paradise if you obey God you worship
Him alone and you do good you live a
good righteous life and there's this
confusion about Jesus being crucified
fied that some people believe that he
died he basically got committed suicide
now what's Islamic stance on this well
the Islamic stance is pretty clear God
says in the hauling put on that Jesus
peace upon him was not killed he was not
crucified and that God had lifted him
towards Davin's and towards got him he
saved them from this humiliation because
he saved them from this year so can you
go ahead and give us a taste now can you
go ahead and actually recite this we
know that if we look at any other
scriptures that we don't have any
originals for instance you look at the
Bible it's not trying to disparage on
anybody but you don't you know Bible
scholars tell us the reality is we don't
have the originals of Matthew or Paul's
letters or of any other book of the New
Testament or the Old Testament so that
the scribes who were copying these
manuscripts changed the text that they
were copying sometimes by accident
sometimes they just made mistakes they
were sleepy or incompetent or whatever
but sometimes it looks like scribes
actually thought the text should say
something other than it did and then
they so they would change the text some
places it looks like it's a manipulation
of the tax where where the author wants
to change where the scribe wants to
change what the author said that we
don't have a copy of a copy of copy of
anything original right but we have
you've memorized the verbatim word of
God no one can come and say look I've
memorized the entire Bible and I know it
in the Hebrew and a Greek look man you
only need Greek food man we tell my kid
you don't even know the Greek language
nor if you did you don't even have the
original but look for our brothers in
humanity they're not yet Muslims you
actually can recite something to us can
you recite to us and translate the
beautiful story about the virgin birth
of Jesus peace be upon all it in Arizona
a Romany minka in quantity Pena hola
mama ana Rosa laura b kelia hey Bella
Coola man
politan a cannoli una mala mia SS nee
bhasha malam aku beli ya para quedar
Nicki father Ramu koala Haden Rawley
nirjala who I attend Lin as you madam
mean what can I am wrong my probably
what did you so beautiful so beautiful
anybody I mean they don't even have to
to understand it but this just
penetrates the heart tell us what you
just said so the crater is saying all
right right there actually what's
interesting is that in in the Quran I've
recited from a chapter which is been
dedicated and he's been named mariana
the story of Mary and PC opener and so
it's the Select verses verses which I
decided Mary may allah may peace and
blessings be upon her is saying that
when angel Gabriel came to her she says
that I seek refuge in the All Merciful
Lord from you unless you are someone who
is God fearing and then angel Gabriel
responded by saying indeed I am a
messenger from God yahuh Bielecki who
demands a kia to bestow upon you o to
gift you with a pure son and so she
responded by saying how is it possible
that i can have a child when no man has
ever touched me and Gabriel responded by
saying the angel Gabriel responded by
saying that this is how God has
commanded it and this is the divine
command of God in this house this is
what it is all I kadali can call our
bookie who are they yeah Hagen and this
is so that God can make Jesus peace upon
him a manifestation of his sign and also
a manifestation of his mercy to all of
mankind so this this is what he's
versatile so this is an article of faith
to believe that Jesus was born without a
father and that the Immaculate
Conception I got me had this is this is
a definite the article this is something
that we believe in you know believing
that Jesus was a messenger and then
believe
did miracles and all of these other
things that he was not crucified that
God didn't commit suicide is that right
so what this person was saying I mean
this is this information yes he's not
representing the Islamic faith the
Islamic faith is exactly what I've
mentioned that along god is saying in
the pier on that this is what I just
mentioned it as and you just you can you
recite can you tell us that the verse
where it talks about which one in the
crowd before we go to break that he
wasn't killed a crucified yeah one on
one map or tell you who I masala boom
what I can should be held on the God
says that they did not kill him there in
our crucify him rather a man was put to
resemble him and that that man was
crucified and that woman pot ooh ooh-hoo
air cleaner and God actually emphasizes
this by saying for sure with certainty
he was not crucified and so and this may
be very difficult for people to
understand how could there be a person
in front of them that was not being
crucified what even in the Christian
Christian faith in our faith as well
just as God is able to replace a go to
Iran in a matter of seconds in front of
the eyes of Abraham peace and blessings
be upon him he can you place a man with
another man in front of people was
amazing when Abraham was called a
sacrifice his son he testing him God
replaced it with the writings that
amazing yes and this makes sense God
didn't commit suicide God is the most
merciful and loving he just forgive
right he just called a god to create our
alone say forgive me forgive me will God
forgive of course definitely that's me
we got to go to break I got so much more
to talk to you about so little time
we'll be right back here on the detail
I'm so tired when I read through the Old
Testament New Testament it didn't make
any sense feel like a walk a thousand
when I booked into the eastern faiths
such as I hinduism and buddhism and
taoism of what not uninspired done yes
got me on my knees I agree with a lot of
their principles and ideas the same
Christianity and Judaism but they just
didn't strike a chord they didn't make
sense but thankfully you've got is long
oh and as a result of such I was not a
fan of religion was on a fan of
organized religion and I took a very
atheist approach towards believe it gets
me through trying times oh I could leave
work go have a bottle of vodka so pack
of cigarettes have a double bacon and
double cheese sandwich go to sleep drunk
and happy come to work the next day and
I was miserable and when I read the
noble goat on Oh what do you think about
Christ what do you think about God who
is allah who was Muhammad it tells me
what's the truth and give me all the
proof was just a little bit of
intelligence and a little bit of
investigation you can see that this
lumps of the boogey man that has been
laid out my yellow is the one the one
the 0 1 1 the whole one I didn't believe
in organized religion animals
to read the Quran I thought to myself
here's another book I can put on the
shelf of fictitious make leave the home
on the lolla took me three nights to
read the Quran and when I was done
reading it I remember thinking that it
was the first and to the state the only
religious book I've ever read that makes
sense the lola from beginning to end it
doesn't contradict yourself it's an
instructional mile lies the one
back here on the Dean show and before we
left we were talking about Jesus peace
be upon do you love Jesus of course i
love jesus pieces but every belligerent
muslim has to love and respect Jesus
peace most people don't know this I mean
you can end up in the Hellfire if you
say I don't believe in Jesus it's
correct is that right that's correct
amazing man come on now I mean look now
we got the beard we got the you know the
sermon of the mount dress right and now
we look we pray like jesus also don't we
I believe so yes that's what we
understand if you if you look at people
not right now go to go to the abbey
Matthew 26 39 and it says and he
referred to Jesus went a little further
and he fell on his face and pray to God
I mean what better description then the
Muslim prayer I mean probably probably
prostrate that's amazing isn't it
absolutely yeah there's actually before
I ask you the next question regarding
this crucifixion I've had a Bible
scholar on the show dr. gero Dierks will
you go to the Dean show calm and watch
his show on the crucifixion and he gives
he went on he graduated with the
divinity degree from Harvard you know
Harvard the prestigious university and
he proves that there were Christian
groups at that time are actually groups
that follow Jesus the true followers of
Jesus were Muslims one who submit to the
will of God they didn't worship Jesus
and they believed that God saved them
from this humiliation you know so
there's a lot of confusion there so that
why is it what can someone do if they're
in a land of confusion and it likes what
we're saying look that worship the
crater not the creation they like this
idea that look God didn't commit suicide
that God is the most merciful you know
but now they're stuck there stuck in a
land of confusion because their parents
taught him you know the the preacher
taught him that so God so loved the
world that he sent Jesus to die for your
sins what do you got to say about this
in and generally when we want to reach
an accurate conclusion in anything went
in terms of knowledge we want to go to
our first hand source not a second end
source if I wanted to know the authentic
teachings of Christianity I would
approach a Christian who practices his
faith and even a scholar if I could
likewise if a person wants to understand
the true teachings of Islam I wouldn't
advise that they believe everything they
hear in the news or in the media or what
the parents
been teaching them but rather approaches
scholar approach a knowledgeable Muslim
who understand his faith you can find
someone like that at the at the mosque
and ask them about what is Lama presents
and if they ask the right person they'll
reach and arrive at the correct
conclusion if they're not arriving at
the correct conclusion is only because
they're not doing the research properly
and if they want to do the research
properly first and foremost I have to
have an open heart be ready to accept
the correct answer you know I have an
open heart I don't work off a bias don't
work off of an answer that you want to
hear what your desires want you to hear
but I have an open our be honest with
yourself and ask someone who you know
and I try to approach someone that can
leave lead you to the right conclusions
you can find that at the mosque I can
devour a Muslim who's practicing and
then you're arrived at that quite moving
surface van yes definitely tell us that
goes is my next question that you know
we believe definitely there's been cases
where people have actually wanted to you
know pay the the Muslims to keep their
mouths open because the businesses
around the MAS and some of these these
areas the crime was so rapid but when
the Muslims moved in the crime went down
you know they start to save that the the
communities from destruction because you
know Islam is just about inviting too
good you know calling people too good
and helping to change people's lives for
the for the better you guys actually
have a mas that you're and we're seeing
this I mean we're seeing this happen
that the mosque people are just you know
coming to Islam it's the fastest growing
way of life in the mosques are getting
you know so crowded that now you have to
have a bigger facility and you guys are
running into that problem now isn't it
no that's correct we as but I dimension
that we I'm the Imam at the bone book
community and we are trying currently to
purchase a building which we don't just
want but we need in order to fulfill the
current demands of our community we need
we have 19 parking spots at the current
facility we have over 50 60 people come
every day for the congregational prayers
so we need a bigger parking lot we have
a sunday school which has fulfilled its
quota
and we have people who are coming but we
don't have enough space to provide them
with so we need a bigger we need a
bigger facility to be able to serve our
community and fulfill their needs so we
are now currently looking into buying a
building in which can fulfill the needs
of the community in terms of the parking
in terms of Sunday School in terms of
having our Friday congregational prayer
there as well our weekly prayer so the
building we are currently purchasing is
two and a half miles away from the
current building it is ideally and
strategically located at a perfect area
where it is going to serve all the
muslims in the bolingbrook and
surrounding areas so we are currently at
a big deficit about a little bit less
than 1 million dollars now or about a 1
million dollar deficit so we are looking
for all the help that we can not just
for ourselves but so that people in the
Beloved Community and the surrounding
areas can have their needs fulfilled in
terms of the spiritual needs and also
their social needs because this is a
building they can also provide a banquet
hall a basketball gym for the youth so
those who would like to contribute to
this you know very noble project they
can simply visit the bone book much to
the website bone broke masjid and you
can just put it in google if you don't
know how to type your proper spell it
out the way i'm saying it bone broke
masjid calm and you can you know make a
donation online through paypal so this
is dissident era that we're currently
taking up and we're looking for all the
help now could did not yet muslims
because everyone has the potential to
submit to the crater that's what I
Muslim is are the people can anyone just
come in can you give them a do if people
wanted a tour they want to see what's
going on maybe some people think a these
guys has got a bomb-making Factory in
there i mean i mean the doors are open
for everyone even in the crème forces
that we've had we've had multiple people
come in non-muslims for their research
projects just they've heard certain
events going on the news they want to
know what's going on what is Islam
really preach so they come in all the
time I have it so if this is it open for
everyone who wants to learn about Islam
and would like to just know what Islam
represents preaches it's
I've pristine teaching they can come in
the doors open friend you get you'll
give them a private tour I can give them
private so anytime you yeah so
everybody's welcome helpful everybody's
work on that was his way of life is for
everybody exactly you're mean you're an
American that's but if you weren't your
Chinese Italian Bulgaria doesn't matter
where you're from it does not matter and
that's the beauty of Islam is that when
you come to the mosque just observe the
congregation of daily congregational
prayer you'll see people from all
different walks of life all different
cultures all different nationalities and
you'll see that Islam is for everyone
yeah and people are coming to Islam
that's why the place is getting over
packed so now now you you you guys found
this place or anybody who wants to
contribute to help out you know now they
can what's to play the older studies
Boland mcmaster com may Allah make
everything easy so you guys can get this
nice facility so people can can learn
this way of life live it and do good
because that's what the message is all
about doing good living a good life
thank you for very much for being with
us thank you for having thank you and
thank you for tuning in to the Dean show
now I know you have an open heart and
open mind so you see that these things
make sense you've got to learn a lot
today you've got learned that look it's
an article of faith for Muslims once you
have children submit freely to the
Creator not the creation that we believe
in love Jesus that Islam is not about
terrorizing people or terrorism and you
see that the mosques are just
overflowing because people are coming to
islam is the fastest growing way of life
in the world and we believe that God so
loved the world that he set prophets and
messengers to guide you to God to guide
humanity to guide people because God and
just create the creation just run away
from the creation God created design in
the case of designer and the one who
designed it he sent the instruction
manual so it was sent at one time to
Jesus another time through Moses and
Abraham all the other messages and they
all came with the same message Islam
submission to the will of the creator
doing good being good staying away from
worshiping creation and running towards
worshiping the crater and encompassing
loving knowing your Creator and
revolving your life around pleasing your
crater because deaf is a reality we will
die and that full bank account of
billions millions and trillions it's all
going to stay behind so do something
right now do something right now before
you change the channel Nadine show is
done ask
ready to guide you no matter what you've
done God and send nobody to commit
suicide for your sins no that doesn't
make sense God sent messengers and all
of them taught us how to repent a guy
ask ask the crater apologize for the
wrong you've done repent and ask God to
guide you guide me guide me guide me and
then be prepared to follow it up with
action look into Islam call us at 1 866
to Islam operators are standing by to
answer your tough questions or if you're
ready to submit if you're ready the
first thing is that you declared that
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the creator of the heavens are earth and
you agree with what's in your very
nature then I'm not going to worship the
creation I want to worship the one and
only create tour then you accept
Mohammed Jesus Moses Abraham all of
those messengers as teachers ones who
came out of the love to guide humanity
and man that just makes sense so if it's
making sense which it is you know it is
then prepare prepare prepare for the day
that the air won't be there anymore and
then you'll be done it be finished
you'll be six feet under in the ground
then it's too late so do it now all of
these distractions bollywood hollywood
all that stuff just numb in the mind now
is the time to get it right so it's not
coincidence that you've tuned into the d
show and you're hearing this for the
first time second time but now is the
time to take some action we're giving
you invitations to accept his way of
life call us at 1 866 to islam and we
hope to see you next week here on the d
show until then remember follow us on
twitter like us on facebook and if you
want to visit us we're going to be at
this event at the bowling book masjid
coming up this weekend so you can see us
there with sheikh use of Estes that's
right the preacher that accepted Islam
Big Texan he'll be there too we'll see
you next time until that peace be unto
you